[Music]
hi fish behind we're talking about the
basic but can work that we do here at
our school in this we have a basic
attack series in art school 2x which
spoke in I don't start with a lot of
attention played pages the booty and the
reason for this is because most of sort
work is really about understanding what
the other person is doing and what
you're doing and what makes good attack
to bat attacks and good defenses and
good counters and all these things it is
important to get the booty practice in
but I generally don't start the students
off with a lot of savuti work because
the reason is that refining cut isn't as
important to them as understanding the
basic theory of how swordsmanship works
so we have it set of five first attacks
which generally if the students kind of
squared away in and how to use the sword
how to swing the sword move of the sword
but more importantly we get the students
squared away with how we're going to be
making our attacks now we're going to
talk about the very first attack here so
the first attack I'm gonna get Josh he
ran in and with me so the first is half
is there's an opening on the line and
you should take that opening so Josh
opens up for me right now
Josh doesn't have a defense in place
that means I have a moment in time where
I can possibly attack so I could come in
and attack this guy now anytime we're on
the line and I get some kind of opening
I should consider attacking that opening
if I wasn't even with a really crappy
person I would say you should always
attack that opening but if I'm dealing
with a crafty person you might have set
something up in that opening that I
should be wary but for the most part if
I don't open it appears on the line I
should be attacking that okay right now
Josh's sorts moved off to the side so
that gives me a perfect opportunity to
come in and attack now when I'm
attacking I want to attack in a nice
counter swings in there my body's not in
range for that body strike right I'm
also creating opposition wherever his
sword is so nothing he were to attack hi
on that line you can see these coming in
and attacking my head here
my swords already in place so I'm
naturally defending that if he had
dropped his sword to the other side when
I came in so yep if you drop this sword
to the other side when I came in I
actually don't have a nice line there's
a defender so yeah his sword was dropped
to the other side I would come in this
way and now you can see this is my body
and he goes for my head
he's not naturally have an opposition to
that right so I've always think
attention to where this sword is and
that determines how my feet will come in
for the attack so the first basic attack
the main idea of this attack his options
open up here and his sword is over there
on my left when I step in I want to step
in with the right side of my body that
way I'm here able to make an attack on
Josh now when I make that attack he
cannot swing on the same line in
campaign because I'm defended and it be
swings lower than that my body's out of
the way so I understand we're always
accounting for that secondary attack
that can happen if his sword is on the
other side I would step in that way
Sally the majority my body would be
defended against his next possible
attack for our second attack the idea
here is that I don't have an opening on
the line so I can make an opening on the
line by not for the side and coming in
like this now when I do that I'm
following all the same rules as the
first attack so the first is that taught
me that if I had an opening I can attack
and the way in which I should attack on
this opening is to the east went in for
my body they would miss me it'd be songs
there for my head I would have
opposition to that in the second one all
we're learning is that I can clear the
line so I don't have to move myself
anywhere right now I can here's weapon
out in line I am the same situation I
had in first attack and I came in now
when I'm making this crowd I action I
want to do everything with my
and now the reason we're done everything
with my backhand is by meeting my front
hand in the center
I still have protection on this center
line so if I were to go like this and
jostle fast she's able to come in she'll
be able to raise my hands up in divinity
now remember my arms who faster than a C
so because we're at this distance if he
comes into attacking I've got family
moved my hands faster than he can move
my feet his feet so I would have a
defense in place so if I do but if I
move my hot hand over here it's gonna be
a lot harder for me to get that
defensive place it's not impossible it's
my hands move back but a lot more work
so when I'm feeling like this I want to
practice my backhand this gives me a
little more defensive place then I use
my backhand sword out of the way and I
also use that to set my next action then
I'm moving in here bang and I can hit
right on top like this so that's how I'm
setting up my second action I don't have
an opening on line but I can clear the
line or an opening to come in next these
is I can change my angle so the third
type of attack we have is I can simply
change my angle which means I could step
over here and attack Josh now when I do
that I want to do this in such a way let
me attack my head begging is y'all gonna
have infinity attacked my body then I
would be out of the way so I'm setting
this up so that way I have that
opposition always so instead of making a
la opening or just naturally happening
OB I've made my evening but coming off
to the lines instead of removing his
sword front one I simply remove myself
from the line and I can get a really
nice attackers now the only problem with
this certain attack basically one of the
easiest ways to get the tax cut like a
bustling manager which is to get a
superior angle the problem of it is if I
come in towards this guy by raising my
hands up and he's really clever he's
going to put something in the way for me
to throw up for me get dressed it right
it's going to switch stance here real
quick so the board the taxi says come
again while regulating that sword so I
have suppression of the sword now as
maintaining the suppression diet
suppression old-line and tell them ready
to launch my attack now when I do this
service if I pull a sword back I will
have no suppression in the center to be
easily stabbed mean that's not good what
I'm going to do is move my body into the
sword like this now he turns towards me
to attack you see I'm instantly defended
here now as I'm launching my attack I'll
naturally be pulling myself off the line
so he sweeps through here he misses me
so what is fourth attacks done it's a
gouken to God it's designed to keep his
sword in check while I move in so I'm
moving it at an angle exactly like I did
on the last one but this time I'm
keeping his sword in check so we're here
like this as mid on that line is swords
in check as I make my attack my fog is
coming off the line as he sweeps in and
I'm defended completely that entire time
this is our fourth attack which salute
Guinea gosh fifth attack we talked about
this school is the for us the thrust is
the best attack because it leaves the
fewest openings for me so I don't have
to set my sword and attack right there's
a long history of arguments about what's
a better kind of attack and for us or a
slasher cut the it really depends on the
situation
one of the nicest things about the
thrust is I don't have to create an
opening to attack first right I also
until these one action to attack in
order to attack with a cut I always have
to set the cut and make the cut in this
position I can simply thrust in
immediately so no no preparatory action
on that and no natural defenses are
known unnatural openings when I come in
so we're here so the sword I slide in
like this at a slight angle and I'm
taking a centerline
controlling it sort of suppressing it
the whole time so the best attack that
could possibly make is a control his
sword the best leads the fewest openings
for me and comes in a really nice small
angle unable to get him and that's our
fifth basic attack these are the five
basic attacks that we train students
with and we move them through from how
successful attacks work using these five
basic attack methods I'm Christopher hi
stay tuned for the next video